all right crystal
crystal uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally tell us obispo san
luis obispo up in central california yes
sir wine country
yeah and uh tell me about your family
growing up you had both your parents no
i decided my mom and my stepdad my
father was in and out of prison
and i was
i was taken away from my mom i made a
word of the court when i was 14.
why did that happen
they said i was an out-of-control team
but i don't know if they
they
the basic
basic
founding when they took me away was
general neglect
by my mother oh your mom yeah was your
mom into drugs or anything yeah very bad
alcoholic
and drug addict
um committed adultery
she was a she wasn't a very good
influence
how far did you go in school i'm a high
school high school graduate what kind of
kid were you in high school
um
i was a social butterfly but i my junior
and senior year i shaped up and i got my
education and played basketball and was
president of the yearbook committee
things like that oh great
and what did you do after you left home
i became i got pregnant and married
right away well you did
so my oldest my oldest is almost 21.
were you around to race your kid
no my day was he was taken away
because of drugs as well no he was taken
due to the fact that i didn't know how
to nurture him
they said
because i wasn't properly nurtured as a
child
so what kind of stuff did you have to
learn were you unable to do for your
child they take it away
they said that i didn't know how to like
i didn't know how to comfort him i
didn't know how to
when it when it came to loving him i
knew how to love him i knew how to
change his diaper i knew how to clothe
them i know how to do those the basic
things but i didn't know how to comfort
him and
sue them
basically not sure
and they took the baby away
when he was eight weeks old
did you handle that
it was devastating i um i did my court
my court
order i did all that i followed towards
my case plan
um but in the end they ultimately
decided that he would be better off
being awarded the court and adopted out
i would think a mother would learn
whatever is required to keep her child
yes
but that didn't happen
no
so where'd your life go after after your
first child was taken away
um
in turn
i still didn't turn to drugs and alcohol
yet
i um i just
i just started running around
with different people just started
living on the streets
hanging out
basically
and then about a year and a half after
he got taken away is when i got
addicted to the drugs
and that was you're in your early 20s
then yeah well
yeah 20 21. yeah
what drugs were you playing around with
methamphetamines is that still your drug
today no
no what are you using today today i do
smoke spice
which is probably worse
it's it's like any other chemical you
put in your body you have to learn how
to control it
do you think you've got spice under
control oh yeah i don't need it i just i
don't do whatever i'm smoking every day
i smoke it once in a while spice is a
dangerous drug i see all these carcasses
laid out on san pedro street yes that is
definitely what they are doing on san
pedro street
smoking spice
it's very cheap it's like a bucket joint
yes
but do you know what it is
it's a spray that's it's a spray that's
sprayed onto a
potpourri or alfalfa
they're basically just
putting chemicals on weeds and putting
them into joints and you guys smoke them
for a while
what's your what's the effect from that
it keeps heroin out of my it keeps me
from sticking a needle here in the
mirror oh it does
so you're using heroin before this yes
heroin is my drug of choice
and the spice helped you stop using
heroin
i've never heard that before
interesting
and how do you support yourself now
i get general assistance
um food stamps
and
i do i can i i do if somebody pulls over
and asks
me to do the yard work i'll do it i'll
just do the yard work i'll help i'll do
anything for you yeah i saw you
recycling that's where i just picked you
up yeah i'll do anything for an extra
buck so you won't do sex work no
you accept that yeah you're one of the
few women down here not doing sex work
no
have you done it before no
never no
it seems like an easy option for so many
women it is but not for me good for you
and where are you staying now you've
been homeless before yes but you have
housing now yeah well temporary housing
at valley ground and there they just um
brought in emergency section 8 vouchers
for us
so the l.a grand is a is a very nice
hotel downtown in the heart of downtown
l.a not skid row no it's very nice it's
a five-star hotel and it's over
it's
totally taken over by homeless people
and drug addicts yes it has been it's
crazy i just pulled up there yes
to visit somebody and uh
i couldn't believe it it's like it's
it's basically a skid row in in in a
hotel in a very nice hotel yes
i can't imagine how long that's going to
last um funding is up in september
everyone everyone's out in this end of
september well i don't know because they
said that the funding will get read
they'll get their funding again
and they'll get
re-refunded before i get another year
but
who knows
yeah it's an interesting i'll be out of
there by then where will you go on
wherever my section eight loss or takes
me okay that'll get you housing
somewhere else somewhere in l.a county
it's an interesting way to solve the
problem
i don't know that it solves any problem
but if it gets people out of off the
sidewalk of street yes he does skid row
you've been homeless here on skid row
before
um when i before i went into the alley
ground i went
how was that i didn't like it
it was very scary what kind of stuff
would happen to you um i got i got my
ears severed off on valentine's day
like scooter got thrown at my head my
ear my ear the top half of my ear got
severed off
i'd have it stitched back on my head's
thing about stabbed in the back of the
neck
um
he's just
just stupid people doing stupid things
yeah
it's a horrible life down here
do you have any friends yeah you do
these are
people on the street
um some some of them are some of them
most of them aren't most of my friends
are from back home in san luis
obispo that i still keep in contact with
do you have one child
no i have six you have six where are the
other five they are um they're they're
all grown they're all
well except for my
the two that the two that are younger
they're passed away they passed away um
and there's one there's one she's only
she's 14.
you know the other ones are 18 and over
did you raise the
you raised the older ones yes
so you weren't using when you were
raising them
no
so you started using you you stopped and
then
i was using when i got pregnant i
stopped using
and then i took care of my oldest
daughter who's 18 now
and
i didn't use with her
and then
jonathan i didn't use with
either and then um
isis i started to use between jonathan
and isis
but then i stopped because before i got
pregnant with isis how did your two
youngest pass away
um when was a stillborn and the other
one the 11 year old jonathan died of a
cardiac arrest
oh my god sorry
and you you came to l.a what what age
like you know like
i've been here you're gonna have two
years ago so three eight
what made you come out here
just the same change of scenery
even though you have kids up in
san luis obispo you decided no my kids
are my kids are in bakersfield
in vegas so your kids are scattered
about but yeah you decide to come here
my youngest lives with my oldest
and then
my daughter's daughter lives in las
vegas yeah
you still have concentration
you still have contact with the kids
where do you see your life going from
here how old are you can i ask i'll be
40 on tuesday
where do you see your future going
i see it starting to step up and get
brighter
i really do i've made some i've made
some necessary changes
i'm still continuing to make some
unnecessary changes yeah
and um
we'll see what happens from there
and you think you can put down the spice
oh yeah
i can put it down anytime
i just choose not to right now
what's your biggest regret
losing my kids
using my kids when i did
not paying attention to the
not paying attention to them
when i should have
so they took away your first child but
the other ones you were able to keep
except for my youngest she got taken
away as well
no that was for drugs again no she just
got she
she got taken away due to me being
homeless and not having a place to go
so she and she lives with her oldest her
old my oldest her brother
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
most important thing i've learned
the value of family
value of family and having what it means
to have a family
even if it's not blood
all right crystal well thank you so much
for sharing your story
welcome and i wish you the best of luck
with wherever you go from here thank you
hope you get housing all right well
thank you